it's another year so we got another Call
of Duty and as always it has sparked a
debate about skill based matchmaking
there's been a ton of discourse on both
sides including a lot of it coming from
content creators who are against
Activision's choice to include it now
are these complaints warranted or are
Cod players just mad that they have to
get good
okay for those that don't know skill
based matchmaking is basically what it
sounds like even in Pub lobbies you're
going to be matched up with players that
have a similar skill level to you and
almost every year when a new Cod comes
out the internet gets filled with
players complaining about it now you
might be asking yourself why playing
against opponents that have a similar
skill level to you rather than someone
who started the game an hour ago seems
like a perfectly reasonable thing in
fact it would almost make more sense if
people were upset that this wasn't the
case
right well to a large part of the Cod
Community no many fans of the series
think that a heavily tuned MMR system
should not exist outside of ranked modes
recently Tim the tatman actually came
out and explained that sbmm is the main
reason he switched over to br's over the
last few years after streaming Battle
Royale
for majority of my career I'll throw
that in their quote
I just that's what I really love
streaming can I be completely honest
with you guys if sbmm wasn't a thing I
would stream multiplayer but Tim isn't
the only one Doc and plenty of other
content creators have also shared their
thoughts on the discourse but a lot of
people who are on the outside or even
enjoy skill based matchmaking think that
streamers are just complaining because
it's not good for Content gone are the
days that streamers could hop into any
Lobby and just stomp a father of four
that was just trying to unwind after an
eight-hour work day but to be completely
Fair there are actually a lot of good
arguments against skill based
matchmaking some that I didn't even
understand myself until now I just think
that streamers and content creators
aren't doing a very good job explaining
it so let's try to break them down like
I said before the idea of skill based
matchmaking does make sense and it
exists in a lot of multiplayer games and
in a perfect game it would probably be
the best way to go about handling things
but as we know Cod is a franchise that's
far from perfect there is a lot of
cheese in COD from slide canceling to
other insanely broken Meadows and
although pulling off these annoying
mechanics isn't difficult casual players
likely aren't going to put in the effort
to use them but as you get better
veterans start getting put in more
difficult lobbies they're going to be
filled to the brim with [__] crack
kids moving around like demons even if
you choose to not play like that if
you're still a little confused it's
perfectly fine so I think it's very
important that I hammer how big the gap
between a low skill player and a high
skill player is I'm not exaggerating
when I say it's a completely different
game
my [__] God Jesus the main argument
is that the game is just not balanced
enough to make pubs enjoyable at all
skill levels in all play Styles a lot of
above average players just want to
experience the same thing as everyone
else they want to hop into pubs practice
accuracy and grind out skins but as
casual players eventually move on from
the game hardcore fans and those who
choose to stick with it are just going
to be stuck in these Chi Strat lobbies
on top of all that Cod also used to be a
franchise that was best experienced with
friends but with a highly tuned spmm not
everyone is always going to be on the
same level but that means at least one
person in your group is going to get
dragged up or dragged down meaning a
good player is just going to get put
into a server where they Farm Bots or
worse a weaker player is gonna have to
suffer in a sweaty Lobby now I don't
know about you but that doesn't seem
like a good way to keep people coming
back to the game cod also used to be
about just providing an arcady fun
experience where you could go on a tear
and use fun kill streaks but as courage
pointed out that's not what the games
turned into when you play multiplayer
matches today take a look at the overall
kill death ratio of everyone in the
lobby at the end you'll see see very
high very few High tier streaks and
overall players who stand out from that
and what that does is it creates a lot
of frustration as a player you never
have an opportunity to pop off every
single game feels like you're playing
for a million dollars and honestly it
gets really exhausting because there's
never any variance other than spawn get
a kill die or spawn get two kills and
die sure get good is always a fun
argument to make and content creators do
have something to gain if there is no
skill based matchmaking but don't forget
there is a larger fear that looms over
the entire multiplayer experience if
above average players want to enjoy the
game without having to sweat they're
just going to lead to Warzone which is
exactly what happened with modern
warfare 2019 after its first month or so
modern warfare 2019 started to fall off
a bit until Warzone caused the game to
explode again but ever since then almost
all of Activision's resources have gone
into war zone leaving those who want to
enjoy the traditional multiplayer
experience in the dust and if you want
actual evidence of that look no further
than the past two releases Cold War in
Vanguard just became new ways for
Activision to funnel more weapons and
cosmetics into war zone the multiplayer
experience almost got no love Modern
Warfare 2 is supposed to be different
but if the main player base starts to
leave again to avoid the sweat we're
probably just going to see the same
thing happen again now for full
transparency I've put about 30 hours
into the game so far and I'm having a
pretty good time with it maybe this says
more about my skill level but I feel
like movement just isn't as powerful as
it used to be because I don't find
myself slamming my [__] head against
the wall every match I'm in servers
definitely feel more challenging than
they did back in let's say Black Ops 1
or 2 and I enjoy that but I'm also
perfectly fine with hopping into ranked
if I want to experience that at the end
of the day the argument isn't completely
against lobbies being more fair skill
wise they absolutely should be there has
almost always been some form of Silent
MMR in the Cod franchise and to say
there shouldn't be is kind of silly but
I think an argument as to how precise
the ranking algorithm needs to be in a
pub Lobby is a perfectly reasonable one
to have ranked modes now exist in COD
for a reason and maybe letting off the
gas a little with sbmm will force devs
to put more work into making the
competitive experience more rewarding
and fleshed out all you're doing
the next tier of sweat lobbies with
examples I
lost Legends and I get better and I work
on my accuracy and I work on my teamwork
and I rank up and I get better and I
move up the ranks and I see my rewards I
get better rewards at the end of the
season and I'm in the better lobbies and
I see that I'm in the better lobbies
but with a silent MMR system all you're
doing is moving up the ranks without
having any of that benefit and without
having any opportunity to have your
pop-off games but like I said before
this is actually a much larger
conversation about game balance as a
whole and what exactly Activision wants
their game series to look like and
although I still see arguments on both
sides of the subject it feels like every
year the conversation just gets so
caught up in itself and then Warzone
comes out and takes over the game again
what do you think about skill-based
matchmaking
playing this game the first time playing
this game right I went [__] off right
the next game I went against a bunch of
sweats and I went like three and like
30. I was like oh my